en el último estrechamiento de los lazos
entre washington y taipei eeuu está un
paso más cerca de financiar la defensa
taiwanesa después de que el comité de
relaciones exteriores del senado
aprobara el proyecto de ley beijing se
apresuró a amenazar con consecuencias si
el proyecto de ley sigue siendo revisado
avanzado incluso aprobado como ley
sacudirá en gran medida los cimientos
políticos de las relaciones entre china
y eeuu y tendrá consecuencias
extremadamente graves para la paz y la
estabilidad en el estrecho de taiwán si
se aprueba en el senado y en la cámara
de representantes- este proyecto de ley
hará que washington financia la defensa
de taiwán con 4500 millones de dólares
en cuatro años aunque eeuu ha vendido
armas a la isla durante décadas nunca ha
proporcionado ayuda militar directa
mientras china alerta sobre una
provocación el senador bob menéndez
presidente del comité de relaciones
exteriores insiste en lo contrario
caracterizando al proyecto de ley como
un elemento disuasorio el proyecto de
ley también detalla las sanciones que se
aplicarán en caso de que china intente
tomar la isla por la fuerza cuando la
presidenta de la cámara de representante
nancy pelosi desafío a beijing y realizó
una visita a taiwán este año china lo
consideró entonces una provocación y
tomó represalias con ejercicios
militares alrededor de la isla algunos a
menos de 20 kilómetros de la costa se
entiende que la casa blanca se opuso a
la visita de pelosi en aquel momento
pero no hizo ninguna declaración oficial
esta vez no ha dicho si el presidente
baiden firmará el proyecto de ley pero
ha confirmado que el mandatario quiere
trabajar con el congreso para reforzar
el apoyo bipartidista taiwán entre
washington y beijing la soberanía de
taiwán todavía seguirá siendo un objeto
de discordia